il est souvent bien difficile de savoir
que l'on est un aidant surtout dans le
cadre familial un terme nouveau qui
désigne un rôle assumé la plupart du
temps par un proche mais même s'il est
assumé il n'en reste pas moins usant
arrivé à bout de souffle véronique est
venue demander des conseils et si
possible une assistance c'est pas parce
que je suis aidant j'ai besoin d'être
aidé en fait je suis aidée par mon mari
parce que j'ai une maladie incurable et
je suis aidant de ma mère parce que ma
mère a perdu la mémoire aussi à court
terme après il y a mon père qui est
malade qui est en fin de vie en
épade et puis qu'il faut aider aussi
donc bon ça saute comme ça et puis puis
c'est compliqué à
vivre c'est une première à châteauin
mais ces cafés des aidents sont de plus
en plus prisés ce sont pour beaucoup les
mêmes questions qui reviennent mais
c'est surtout ce besoin de parler qui se
fait sentir en faito mais c'est un long
chemin en fait de se rendre compte qu'on
estans et souvent on s'en rend compte
quand on est déjà dans un état de
fatigue ou d'isolement ou ces choses-là
qui permettent de dire ah oui il y a un
problème en fait de ces espaces de
partage émanent des fois des situations
d'urgence et c'est tout l'intérêt cibler
pour aider de manière efficace on va se
rendre compte que il y a un besoin qui
n'est qui est plutôt matériel euh je
sais pas moi quelque chose qui va nous
aider à déplacer une personne d'un
endroit à l'autre pour améliorer euh
donc la mobilité pour améliorer la façon
dont on peut faire sa toilette ou faire
une toilette voilà l'association famille
rurale a mis en place CIN cafés de ce
genre en heur etloire et compte en
ouvrir un autre prochainement à nos gens
le retrou